[Music]
[Applause]
uh Chris Sims former NFL quarterback a
pro football talk live co-host with our
friend Mike Florio NBC football night in
America analyst as well Chris we start
with the most important question that
you will face
this weekend
when's the last time you went to Hooters
gosh it's been a long time
um man I used to be pretty frequent when
I was in my days of Tampa in in Tampa
Bay with the Buccaneers Groot Gruden was
really good friends with the owner of
Hooters so we usually had like a card in
our locker some point during the off
season that gave us free Hooters right
so it was like okay when in doubt let's
go to Hooters there right and so it's
been a it's been a while I'm gonna say
it's probably been I'm 12 years 13 years
since the last time I've set foot in the
Hooters I think that's that's about
right have you brought your children to
Hooters
uh no nor will that I mean Hooters you
know no and the the big debate is would
I will I ever really go there again I I
don't know you know okay I mean gosh the
outfits are not that great anymore for
2022 it's not that great and the food
stinks so I don't think I'll be getting
any sponsorship from them anytime soon
nor do I want my like young kid or my
daughter to have to sit there and look
at Hooters while they eat below Hooters
food below average Hooters food
that was a uh that was a deep dive there
there was right yeah that's what you
brought me here uh Jeff Saturday seemed
like he was
um a little defensive when uh he was
questioned whether he had the cry
criteria to be the head coach and uh he
had this to say
I'm completely comfortable in who I am
as a man bro I know I can lead men I
know I know the game of football and I'm
passionate about it I have no fear about
are you as qualified as somebody else
bro I spent 14 years in the locker room
I went to playoffs 12 times I got five
dudes in the Hall of Fame that I play
with it you don't think I've seen
greatness you don't think I've seen how
people prepare how they coach how they
GM how they work I mean one Super Bowl's
been to two like here's the deal man
none of us are promised a good job I may
be terrible at this and after eight
games I'll say God bless you I am no
good I may be really good at it I got no
idea but I dang sure ain't gonna back
down I can tell you that okay does he
understand why we may be a little
suspicious about this scenario or maybe
shocked I I I I mean it didn't seem like
it from that answer I I think he
probably does understand I think he's
probably trying just to you know bolster
his argument to why you know he at least
thinks he deserves a chance on this you
know but it's fair for all of us to
question I I don't think he's that
unrealistic to to realize that you know
again all those great things he said
sure that's great but it really still
has Jack diddly squat to do with
coaching it doesn't it doesn't does you
know okay so now you've never organized
a practice schedule in your life now you
have to do that every day let alone
organizing a bunch of other issues and
now you've never held a meeting and had
to go over how's our game philosophy
going to do offense defense how are we
going to do this and this is where so
you've never done that before let alone
now you're in the game and you've never
managed situations and okay you've never
really even taught a position group in
the NFL so that's where you know we all
question that right right I mean that
that's the big thing I know he can lead
men I know he knows football and the
base principles of the game that you got
to do to be to be successful but damn
there's been a lot of Hall of Famers and
guys like that who have claimed they can
do that and Coach a football team and
they can so that's this is a this is
going to be an interesting experiment
and and one of the more intriguing games
now on Sunday just because I want to see
how he does manage himself in the team
or the Colts tanking
I mean I don't think it's like
Manchester managerial tanking I I mean
maybe I don't think they are I don't I
wait wait wait wait do you think that
Sam Ellinger should be the starting
quarterback over Nick Foles
um
I I think it was worth the shot to see
to see if they're like at least he's the
guy we know what Nick Foles is but they
said the rest of the seat do you think
Sam Ellinger is a better quarterback
than Nick Foles right now for this team
no um no probably at this moment no no
could it be maybe another week or two
down the road he could be you know again
I think the problem here is when you
take the team as a whole right Nick
Foles is gonna go into the same problems
that Matt Ryan is not a big arm can't
move in the pocket they can't protect
he's gonna get hit a lot right so
allenger at least has some movement
ability some quarterback design run he's
a big thick strong guy that didn't help
him he got stacked nine times against
the Bengals well I I get it I mean
nothing's gonna help him period against
the the Patriots last week you're right
they got issues I mean their offense it
stinks they misevaluated their the
strength of their offensive line and how
good it was going to be again
um so yeah I mean I guess to your
question they'd be a little bit better
with Nick Foles but I understand them
going with Sam Ellinger and honestly
with Jim irsay here I I think he thinks
he might be finding like you know a
diamond in the rough here as far as like
he might be onto something it doesn't
feel like he was like let me pick the
worst possible candidate to tank I think
he's going like I think I'm gonna bring
something into the game that nobody's
ever seen before and we're gonna shock
the world that's what it feels like at
least just from some of the statements
they've they've made yeah hey I think
it's great that he has no coaching
experience I think that's great you know
right he's not going to coach in fear
like these other coaches do in the NFL
we're talking to Chris Sims pro football
talk live co-host how would you manage
an injury that Josh Allen has if if
you're Josh Allen
uh can you play differently
not really I mean you know it's like he
doesn't know any different than let me
unleash that ball and throw it 100 miles
per hour throw it you know 70 yards down
the field this is totally gonna just be
on the feel of that elbow can you shoot
that up
get you can shoot it up but you gotta
yeah you can shoot it up you definitely
can but but you know again you don't
want to shoot it up to the point where
if it's so inflamed and bothered that
you're making it worse as you're
shooting it up and it's already got an
issue and now you don't realize it's
hurting because you've shot it up and
that's when oh no something doesn't feel
right oh damn I tore that nerve or that
you know that ligament so that's what I
think you got to be worried about with
this one this is not the type of thing
you would want to shoot up and I you
know again I don't have much experience
with this one nor do I can I really say
I know anybody through my history you
know shooting it up as a quarterback I
don't know if that would really work I'd
be afraid that I just it's too numb I
don't have feel for the ball right Dan
so that would be I think a thing you
just take a lot of aspirin and hopefully
that I can grip the ball and Let it
Loose and I don't know he's such a freak
of nature I just have a feeling it's
going to come Sunday morning and they're
going to be like he could and play all
right we're good and and it just that'll
be that Cowboys go to Lambo yeah and I
keep waiting for Aaron Rodgers to be
Aaron Rodgers yeah
should I stop waiting for Aaron Rodgers
to be Aaron Rodgers yeah you should you
definitely should it's it's something
I've been really kind of beating into my
podcast really from week one it really
reared its ugly face against the
Minnesota Vikings you know I think we
even talked about it last year Dan when
we did the quarterback rankings in the
off season and when I went back and
watched him at the end of last season
and the way he played against the 49ers
in the playoff game it's just it's Ultra
conservative you know one they don't
have the weapons and the offense to be
explosive necessarily two I if they did
I don't know if he'd throw it anyways
but how much is this Aaron Rodgers how
much is this on the Packers or the
coaching staff I I I think you know
everybody could deserve a little blame
here there's no doubt about that
um but I I think a lot of it's got to go
on Aaron Rodgers too I mean he's Aaron
Rodgers we watch Clips every week of
going wait the pocket's fine there's
people open throw the damn ball I don't
know what we're doing so there's too
much much of that and then you know last
week of course they were bad
interceptions they weren't like oh man
he got a little unlucky it was like no
you threw the one off somebody's helmet
the next one you threw it like five
yards too short to bhaktiari the third
one Guys open down the middle but he
double clutched it like four times
before he finally threw it and by that
time it was too late and he wasn't open
anymore so
um yeah it's a lack of natural
aggressiveness within the normal flow of
the offense let alone a quarterback that
doesn't want to throw it down the field
and you know the defense is good it is
very good it's not dominant and doesn't
make a ton of plays to help them get the
ball back all the time I don't expect
them to win this weekend with the
Cowboys rolling into town uh sell me on
Thursday Night Football Carolina against
Atlanta
well Atlanta's not dead right I mean
they're not we see I mean again with the
the NFC South I'm still going to pick
the the Bucks to win it but I think like
we see the Bucks are what they are
they're not going to just dominate
football anytime you know soon here
every game is going to be a struggle for
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers so the Falcons
are going to be able to hang in here I'm
very impressed again with Arthur Smith
the second year in a row he's got that
brablish quality about him where he
knows what to do on a weekly basis wait
this is what we got to do this week to
win he knows exactly you know what his
team is and he doesn't you know have any
disillusions about that so they play
Within that framework a lot like the
Giants in a lot of ways manages the game
the right way that way so I think that's
what you're looking at is this a Falcons
team that can continue to hang around
and be annoying and then the Panthers
there's not much to look at there other
than let's see if they can maybe make
some exciting plays and keep this fun
like it was a few weeks ago
do you think Baker may feel to be a
starting quarterback ever again
I'm going to say yes at some point but I
think we've seen now the journey might
be you know it might be a little while
he might be at the point where next year
yeah he's relegated to a backup and he's
gonna have to wait his opportunity but I
do think he still has starting caliber
skills as a quarterback it's hard you
know it was a hard situation he was put
in and as you know you watch a ton of
football the Carolina offense it's just
it doesn't got much to offer it's just
it's not that great and it's it's
underwhelming X's and O's and creativity
to go with it so that's an issue but
yeah eventually I do think he'll get a
chance again and be a starter the Niners
are favored by seven Sunday night
against the Chargers yeah that's a big
number
it's a big number it's a big number I
understand it I you know two things
49ers
I mean the offense this is the first
time we're gonna see the Debo Samuel
Christian McCaffrey full unveiling the
Chargers can't stop the run they don't
have enough big people on their defense
and now you got to play this group and
the way they run the ball with Shanahan
unveiling you know tricks all over the
place oh that's scary and then you know
the other amazing thing about the 49ers
is number one defense in football and I
mean what have they've been missing like
three or four of their best players on
defense for most of the year that's
what's amazing the 49ers to me Dan are
one of those teams that I know they're
four and four right now but I think with
all said and done we're gonna put them
in the class of the Eagles the Cowboys
the bills the Chiefs is one of the
better teams in football I do I think
they have that type of potential and
what also the the that I understand this
seven point spread the Chargers can we
get some like game planning can we get
some shots down the field we got a
quarterback that's got the greatest arm
one of the greatest arms in the history
of football and all they do is throw it
four yards right I know they got the old
coordinator are from the the Saints and
it's the Drew Brees offense but okay can
we draw a few plays on the dirt to throw
the ball down the field or do we just
have Justin Herbert throw every ball
five yards and he's gotta smash it in
there between two guys for a five-yard
game that's where it's I think the seven
points is and that's where it's scary
and I would think the 49ers gonna cover
that spread honestly Dan let me go back
to the Packers Before I Let You Go yeah
they've lost five in a row right give me
the scenario where Jordan love becomes
the starting quarterback hmm
gosh I I would think that maybe you'd
have to
kind of lose the next four down the
stretch and go to like three and nine
I'm not even sure if they'll do it then
I don't know would you I
yeah you know
um probably not I probably not I think
I'd probably look at it and go no I mean
Aaron Rodgers you're you're here next
year we think you're gonna be here for
50 million next year you're here this
year some of the issues we're having are
because of you we're not going to give
you a free pass and let you be on the
sidelines and watch us all struggle now
I'd make him be a part of the struggle
too I would and I'd go damn if you want
to come back next year we got to work on
some things these young guys and kind of
set the groundwork for next year uh I I
I don't know I guess that's the way I
think a little bit uh but but I haven't
thought about that a lot it's a good
question maybe maybe it is one of those
things where they lose the next four
games and then after that bye week they
decide hey it's over let's get out of
here let's go with Jordan love and see
if he can be something but it's it's
very weird in that Green Bay situation
right now yeah because I don't know
how you address this with your season
ticket holders do you want to see Jordan
love or would you still rather see Aaron
Rodgers right I mean that right that's
where you let you let your season ticket
holders in and say hey we're trying to
see if we have a quarterback of the
future or do you want to see the current
quarterback as well I wonder I wonder
how Packer fans would vote if you said
we're not playoff eligible
we're paying Aaron 50 million dollars a
year
with five games left do you want to see
Jordan love to see if we we would pick
up his fifth year option
I would imagine they'd want to still see
you know Aaron Rodgers the legend that
he is okay uh I I would imagine and you
know again this is things where I feel
like
you know Green Bay may need to press him
a little bit as the year goes on like
are you coming back next year can we get
an answer now can we get it now yeah
good luck with that where you're gonna
press him
on anything I know he's not going to
tell them he'll tell Pat McAfee and then
we'll probably yeah yeah I know you're
right that's a scene that seems to be
how it works but yeah Green Bay
disappointing Roger's disappointing all
of it default defense really good but I
still thought it would be even more
dominant than what it is and yeah I
think I I think there's a good chance
they legitimately lose the next three
Cowboys Titans Eagles uh oh that that
ain't a good combo for this Packers team
have a great weekend thank you Chris
anytime man tell the guys I said hi
who's the Man Dan guys Chris said hello